i
[Música]
tokio 2020 se ha convertido en la mejor
actuación de la historia paralímpica de
colombia 69 deportistas consiguieron
dejar en alto el nombre del país con
tres preseas doradas 7 de plata y 14 de
bronce 24 medallas en total entre todos
los desempeños loables en la competición
llama la atención el de nelson crispín
un nadador de 29 años que sufre
acondroplasia una enfermedad que afecta
el crecimiento óseo ahora ya es el
máximo medallista de colombia en estas
justas consiguiendo tres medallas en las
categorías de 50 metros mariposa 100
metros pecho y 200 metros combinados
también destaca marta hernández la
primera mujer en conseguir una medalla
para colombia en las competencias de
rio-2016 en esta ocasión se vistió de
bronce para el atletismo pese a su
discapacidad derivada de una meningitis
neonatal hoy se convierte en una de las
mejores atletas de colombia
[Música]
brasil obtuvo su mejor resultado y una
olimpiada en tokio
desde londres en 2012 son 72 medallas de
hecho una sola menos de lo que fué
londres en 2012 son atletas como betty
gómez la más grande de la delegación
tiene 56 años esclerosis múltiple en
2018 tuvo un acb que dejó mitad su
cuerpo paralizado pero eso no le impidió
de ser la mejor lanzadora de disco del
mundo y con eso vuelven los atletas
paraolímpicos a un país donde no todos
están de acuerdo de su valor por ejemplo
el ministro de educación militar rivero
el mes pasado habló a lo que llamó de no
incluso y abismo cree que niños
discapacitados retrasan el aprendizaje
de otros niños en la escuela una una
versión de segregación mientras en las
paraolimpiadas
los brasileños dan
una lección de inclusión superación y
patriotismo
[Música]
venezuela logró siete medallas en los
juegos paralímpicos de tokio 2020 tres
de oro dos de plata y dos de bronce
además de 17 diplomas ubicándose en el
puesto 38 del medallero y como el tercer
país sudamericano con mejor registro
luego de brasil en el puesto 7 y
colombia en el puesto 37 entre los
atletas venezolanos destaca la joven
corredora de 19 años lisvel iberá quien
tuvo una extraordinaria participación al
conseguir colgarse tres medallas dos de
oro y una de plata nivel ignacio sin
parte de su brazo izquierdo y dijo
recientemente en una entrevista que su
vida hasta ahora había estado llena de
muchas dificultades
víctima de mofas e incomprensión de las
personas tímidas encontró confianza en
el deporte luego que un profesor la
descubriera en una carrera callejera y
la pusiera en contacto con un entrenador
y fue en 2017 su debut internacional en
las pruebas de velocidad de los juegos
panamericanos de sao paulo
[Música]